we are born into this world hungry
vulnerable and confused as we go through
life we attempt to eliminate these
feelings by trying to control the
conditions of the world around us we
seek to accomplish and obtain things
achieve higher status acquire wealth or
fame develop power and so on we live
with the persisting hopefulness that in
the future we will have and control
enough stuff to free ourselves of our
emptiness vulnerability and confusion
and find some ultimate happiness and
security outside of ourselves this
hopeful vision of the future might sound
reasonable but perhaps it is what keeps
us contained in our problems to help us
better understand and deal with our
seemingly unquenchable hunger for
ultimate control and happiness outside
of ourselves we will look to the ancient
philosophy of stoicism stoicism is a
philosophy that started in ancient
Greece and was then further popularized
in ancient Rome stoicism is an
especially unique philosophy and how
potently it has withstood the test of
time across thousands of years arguably
the teachings and wisdom of stoic
philosophy are equally if not more
relevant today than ever in recent
history stoicism has found huge appeal
it was used and encouraged by recent
historical leaders like George
Washington Thomas Jefferson and Nelson
Mandela written about by current popular
authors like Tim Ferriss Robert Greene
and Ryan holiday just to name a few and
has found a rather large community on
the Internet stoicism is enduring
popularity is not without good reason
the principles of stoicism can help us
find calmness presence and resilience in
a world of increasingly overt chaos
anxiety and insatiable desire for more
in stoicism we exist in a reality that
does not care about our personal opinion
of it we cannot ask it nicely to remove
the chaos suffering hardship and
uncertainty nor can we will ourselves
onto it with force in order to do so
however stoicism suggests that that does
not mean we are subject to be helpless
victims of the world rather stoicism
proclaims that there are two domains of
life our external being the things
outside of our mind which we cannot
control and the internal our
interpretations and reactions to the
external which we can control when we
persist with the belief that things
outside ourselves or things in the
future
will provide
with the form of ultimate happiness we
become dependent on things that are not
part of us nor part of what we can
control and thus remain endlessly
unsatisfied and unhappy we can and
should pursue the things that we deemed
preferable and interesting and not live
an inactive life however we must ensure
that on our pursuits our focus remains
on the internal and that we work to
derive our sense of joy from how we
think and act within our pursuits no
matter what task we undertake we will do
it wastefully if we assume that any of
what comes beyond the task will provide
anything better than the experience of
focus and presence in the task itself
there's nothing inherently wrong about
working towards and achieving wealth
Fame or power but in the Stoics mind
these things are merely to be enjoyed if
they do work out but not to be depended
on for one's happiness for if one is
dependent on them their happiness and
peace in life are especially susceptible
to being inconsistent taken or never
achieved at all
stoicism suggests that the sign of a
truly successful person is someone who
can be okay without the things he or she
typically desires or depends on for
comfort for no wealth materialistic
abundance fame or power has any value to
a happy life if the person who possesses
them has not yet learned to live
properly without them Roman Emperor and
stoic philosopher Marcus Aurelius was
the most powerful person in the world
during his time he had access to
anything he could have ever wanted
yet he writes almost nothing material is
needed for a happy life for he who has
understood existence with access to the
world Marcus Aurelius lived with little
interest in the self-indulgence of
things outside of himself in order to
develop this fortitude a common practice
and stoicism is to on occasion
temporarily strip oneself of the things
they ordinarily depend on for comfort in
order to prove to themselves how strong
they truly are without the things they
think they need in the peace of classic
literature entitled letters from a stoic
Roman statesman and one of the most
renowned stoic philosophers Seneca
writes until we have begun to go without
them we fail to realize how unnecessary
many things are we've been using them
not because we needed them but because
we had them it isn't our constant
expectation that something outside
ourselves or in the future is needed for
a worthy experience of life that causes
our inability to ever find worthy experi
in life in the first place and led us
from a stoic Seneca discusses the idea
of how to properly handle ones time and
derive meaningful experience when
referring to time Seneca writes I advise
you to keep what is really yours and you
cannot begin to early for as our
ancestors believed it is too late to
spare when you reach the dregs of the
Cask of that which remains at the bottom
the amount is slight and the quality is
vile it is now that we must find time
and it is now that we must find
happiness if it is either that we are
seeking for if we do not focus the lens
through which we view life right now
everything we see from this moment
forward will remain out of focus for the
stoic the ability to find happiness in
spite of what occurs around us is
developed through character and
perspective we must realize that nothing
is good or bad inherently but only our
judgments and interpretations of things
can be good or bad the wise man Seneca
writes is neither raised up by
prosperity nor cast down by adversity
for always he is driven to rely
predominantly on himself and to derive
all joy from himself in other words we
must try to form our perspective to best
serve our ability to remain with
happiness and wonder regardless of the
ups and downs of life
stoicism suggests that we are but a tiny
feature of the entire body of nature and
everything that happens to us is a
matter of relevance and necessity to
everything beyond us in this we must
strive towards an acceptance and
indifference towards everything that
happens to us and instead focus our
attention on controlling our reactions
to the things that happen we must put
our best foot forward acting and living
with self honesty humility and good
virtue and welcome whatever the world
deals us in return good or bad with this
we can begin to free ourselves from the
chaos of the world and find some form of
happiness and presence within ourselves
the practice of stoicism is not easy by
any stretch and arguably to live a
completely stoic life is impossible
likely no person can be without moments
of desire or negative reaction to the
world around them however stoicism gifts
us with a target of wisdom to aim for a
happiness and calmness to strive for
when things are at their apparent worst
in a time where chaos and anxiety run
rampant across our screens where
cultural
to live certain ways and achieve certain
things overwhelm us 24/7 where we spend
a huge amount of time comparing
ourselves to and wanting the approval of
others our sense of happiness and peace
is becoming increasingly susceptible and
it is perhaps through stoicism that we
can attempt to hold on to it starting
from birth we seemingly run if not
sprint through life racing out of every
moment unsatisfied with what life is and
constantly looking to the future for
what life could be if we just obtain
something more or different our culture
is overwhelm us with the reinforcements
of this idea convincing us that in order
to be happy we have to achieve by own
and live perfect unaffected lives this
delusion however frenzies us with an
anxiety that we are then told by culture
we can rid ourselves of if we just
achieve a few more things make a little
more money be a little more popular and
buy a little more stuff creating an
endless feedback loop of unsatisfied
hunger if we cave into this we surrender
our life we give up ourselves we should
not like sheep follow the herd of
creatures in front of us making our way
where others go not where we ought to go
Seneca writes in the stoic view the
stuff we often find ourselves chasing in
life revealed to be rather Petty and
meaningless from a sufficient distance
we don't have much if any control on
what happens to us how people see and
treat us nor what happens because of
what we do and in the big picture none
of it really matters all that much and
so we must define our happiness not by
what we own or achieve not by how others
see us not by some bigger picture of
life but by how we think and see
ourselves and live our own life through
what we deem virtuous and relevant
stoicism tells us we can at last if we
wish calmly accept the conditions of our
and different reality and one-up it with
our own and different attitude in return
[Music]
you